- Social media is filled with
posts that will make you smile
just a little more. And I like
to share the best of them.
This is What I'm Liking.
All right, so this is one of
my favorite What I'm Liking's.
The mystic aquarium in
Connecticut goes to great
efforts to make sure the
creatures in their care live their
best lives, y'all. The
animals and fish get toys.
It's adorable.
Trainers engage them
in games and exercises,
but here's the coolest part.
The aquarium actually brings
in performers to entertain the
sea life. Is that some inception or what?
They're usually entertaining
us, well you get it? Okay.
Just check out hip hop
violinist Big Lux amusing
some beluga whales with a little jig.
(upbeat violin music)
(applause)
- If you aren't moved by a beluga whale
watching a violinist play
then you're dead in your
heart. That is the sweetest thing ever.
We have Big Lux on the
line watching on NBC 10,
WJAR Providence.
What's up, man.
- Hey, what's good?
- Oh my God, well, first of all,
you have like the greatest smile ever.
I'm going to lead with that
and beard game, just saying.
It's nice, it's nice. So this is so rad.
I've never really heard of this,
them hiring entertainment to
entertain the things that
usually entertain us.
So what's it like playing for whales?
And it seemed like they liked you.
- It's a crazy, it's
such a crazy experience.
I mean, you know, who,
whoever gets that opportunity
and you know, they just,
they just decided to clear
out a little bit of space,
you know, during the day for
me to come in and they said,
Hey, play whatever you want.
So I tried to do a whole
bunch of different styles.
I played hip hop, I played rock.
I played country music.
And then I play the Irish thing.
And it was, it was just crazy
because they would react to
everything so differently.
They ran away when I played
Devil Went Down to Georgia,
not feeling it, but I
played that Irish jig
I played the Irish jig and they
just like jumped right off.
- Oh my God, well,
they're Irish, it's fine.
So I love that you play
all different genres.
We got to get you on the show
to play with us when we do
one of our like Kelly-oke things.
That'd be so fun.
So you say this is all part of
a deeper purpose for you, right?
- True. I mean, like, I feel
like I'm on my second lifetime.
I was an active duty army for 13 years.
I was deployed to Baghdad in 2000.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh thank
you so much for your service.
- Yeah. I mean, I just feel like
I'm really lucky to be here.
I was in a, I was in a
bomb searching platoon.
We were combat engineers.
So we got into a lot of,
a lot of difficult situations.
I didn't think I was
gonna necessarily make it
back from that experience.
So I feel like every day is a blessing.
And so I want to use that to
send good vibes to people.
Animals bring people together,
bring animals together.
- All right, good luck
man, I'm such a fan of you.
Big Lux, everybody.
I'm liking your posts right now.
That's not all though, Big Lux.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clarkson show likes to celebrate
those who create fearlessly
just like you, sir.
So they're going to be using
their friction erasable pen to
write you a check for a thousand
dollars. How's that sound?
- A thousand dollars? Thank you.
- [Kelly] I love it. I love it.
Thank you so much, man.
I hope you come play with us soon.